Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to SOMA!
I've been like, dying to play this game by the way.
And in case you guys didn't know, I'm super s-
Hello!
What's this?
HI, little buddy!
Should I free you? Probably not.
Do you have a gun?
Is that a gun?
Don't shoot me
Okay, bye!
Am I supposed to follow you?
Are you following me?
Thanks, little buddy!
I like you.
I wanna name you.. *thinks*
"Tiny.. Sub..."
...
"Tim."
Damnit, gah, gotta be more original than that [chuckle]
I can't just name him Tim! I can't name everything Tim!
Ah..
I'm gonna name you "Bubble Butt"!
'Cause I like you!
'Cause you- you- you- you shoot bubbles out your butt and I like that.
[fart noise] *pbff*
*ding*
'Kay, so I gotta get in there.
C'mon Bubble Butt! You wanna come inside?
Bu-bble, Bubble Butt's all excited!
*ffffffff*
Okay!
*fffffff*
Bubble Butt sure is nice! Look at Bubble Butt helping me out!
Thanks, Bubble Butt!
AWW, thanks, Bubble Butt!
BYEEE! [very loud noise in background]
Have a good time, Bubble Butt!
I'll see ya around!
...Hopefully.
*demon/ghoul screech of sorts*
AHHHH!
WHAT THE FUCK!?!! AHHHHH!!!
OH GOD!
*robo noise*
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to SOMA!
[sound of machine buzzing intensifying, crash]
[chuckling] hehehehehe
[alarm siren going off]
[speaker] "Brace for impact!"
Ohhhh!
[female voice on speaker] "Hold on, the blank just pushes all the blanch out!"
[male voice on speaker] "What does that mean?!"
[female voice again] "If I don't hit Delta, we're dead."
Yay!
[distanced crashing sounds]
"I'll never get this open"
WHY? You don't need to be such a pessimist about things, you can do it!
Believe in yourself! You're a roo-
Bubble Butt!!
[excited and joyous] Is that Bubble Butt?!
[ecstatic] Oh my god, is that Bubble Butt coming to rescue me???!
[quiet hope] Is that Bubble Butt?
Bubble- BUBBLE BUTT!!
OH, it's Bubble Butt!!
Oh my god!!
Thanks, Bubble Butt!
You're the best!
[excited] Oh my gosh, are you going to be following me around now?
Oh, you're so cute!
I love you, Bubble Butt!
Always will!
Like I said, you're my little Bubble Blow and Bubble Butt Biscuit!
[gushing] Oh, you're so cute!
[screen] "The tool chip is busted, we need to get a new tool chip, then switch it."
Okay.
[screen] "I think it would be easier to just take one from a robot."
"The toolbox over there says it has a stun-baton, you can use that."
I am not knocking out Bubble Butt!
I am NOT... knocking out... Bubble Butt.
[whining] I don't wanna hurt Bubble Butt!
I'm sorry!
[sound of shot and crashing]
[another crash]
I feel like a bad man!
But at least Bubble Butt's still here!
Noo, Bubble Butt, don't run away from me!
Bubble Butt!
[teary] Bubble Butt, I'm sorry!
I had to!
[sobs] NoOoOoOoo, Bubble Butt!
[sounds of agony mixed with crying]
[sobs slowly fade out]